salut aujourd'hui c'est la sixième vidéo
sur le rubik's cube c'est à dire c'est
la dernière en tout cas concernant la
méthode de résolution je vous avais
promis quelque chose le jour 1c quand
cinq formules et deux minutes grand
maximum vous réussissiez à faire ce
rubik's cube c'est notre objectif commun
et on est en train de l'atteindre
j'avais promis cinq formules jeu déjà
cramé les cinq on a déjà vu cinq
formules ensemble c'est pour ça qu'on va
reprendre une formule qu'on connaît déjà
la fameuse formule dhd reverser hdh
carré d inverser achkhar et la seule
chose c'est qu'on va pas de l'appliquer
que tout seul quand on va s'en servir
on va coller derrière directement la
même formule mais 100% inversée la seule
chose qui ne bougera pas c'est le
achkhar et parce qu'un carré est
toujours positif donc qu'on déplace deux
fois dans le sens horaire ou deux fois
dans le sens antihoraire ça reviendrait
en fait à faire un 180 degrés que je
passe 1 2 comme ça où 1,2 comme ça je
reviens forcément dans la même position
donc on se sert du dhd inversée hdh
carré d inverser achkhar et est
directement derrière on fait d inverser
à charmer re cdh inversée d'inverser
achkhar et des haches car sa part et
barbare mais d'une part vous connaissez
la première formule donc vous connaissez
la deuxième puisque c'est la même mais
inversés et d'autre part vous allez vous
voir que dans les doigts c'est tout à
fait naturel et c'est pour ça que je
vais passer derrière la vidéo pour vous
faire voir le but du jeu ça va être de
manipuler les coinçant les bougé de
place pour pouvoir les positionner dans
le bon sens vous aurez appliquer cette
double formule plusieurs fois peut-être
une fois deux fois trois fois quatre
fois mais au bout du compte sans avoir à
réfléchir
vous allez terminer le rubik's cube tout
en protégeant tout ce qui a déjà été
fait je le prends dans n'importe quel
sens et j'applique la formule celle
qu'on connaît déjà
donc des haches d'inverser hdh carré d
inverser achkhar et est maintenant
j'aurai applique la même formule mais
inversés donc d inverser h inversée tdh
inversée d inverser achkhar et des
haches carré et regarder ce qui vient de
se passer c'est magnifique le coin s'est
positionné dans le bon sens sans avoir
bougé de place et on a préservé tout le
reste qu'on applique cette double
formule ça bouge les deux coups
un qui sont à gauche ça ne change rien
sur les deux points qui sont à droite
donc je vais juste switcher comme ça
pourrait appliquer la formule la double
formule moi je sais d'expérience à ce
stade là qu'il va falloir encore que je
l'appliquent deux fois des haches
d'inverser hdh carré d'inverser achkhar
et d'inverser achahbar cdh inversée
d'inverser achkhar et des achkhar et je
vais encore appliqué une dernière fois
la double formule donc ce sera la
troisième et dernière fois que je la
fais c'est parti vous avez vu qu'en
termes de mouvements c'est très facile à
se mettre ça dans le corps au premier
coup à la première formule on part comme
ça et au deuxième coup on part comme ça
mais bon on papote on papote qu'est-ce
qui vient surtout de se passer il vient
qu'on vient de finir une bonne fois pour
tout ce rubik's cube
le rubik's cube est enfin finie après
six jours et je vous avais promis qu'il
n'y avait pas d'autres formes n'y a pas
d'autres formules c'est la même inverser
ça compte pas pour une nouvelle formule
retenez bien en tout cas que quand vous
l'avez dans les mains ce sont ces deux
angles là qui vont bouger vous préserver
ça demain je ferai une dernière vidéo
sur les rubik's cube ce sera une vidéo
un petit peu récap et surtout avec un
bonus à la fin une petite figure qu'on
peut faire avec le rubik's cube pour
s'amuser parce que le rubik's cube c'est
la déconne mais merci beaucoup merci à
vous d'avoir suivi toutes ces vidéos sur
le rubik's cube si ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce
en l'air pour le signifier n'hésitez pas
aussi à vous abonner à la chaîne vous
pouvez aussi laisser un petit
commentaire si vous êtes intéressé à
cette série de rubik's cube sachez que
j'ai tourné ça ou youtube space au mois
d'avril j'ai fait cette vidéo d'un coup
donc y compris celles que je vais faire
la juste après puisque comme je me suis
lancé le défi de faire une vidéo par
jour pendant un an j'ai peur du jour où
je vais tomber malade et donc si vous
êtes en train de regarder ça c'est soit
que j'étais malade soit on est au mois
de juillet et si on aimait juillet c'est
à dire que je suis en vacances au
mexique et que j'ai mis ces vidéos là
avant de partir rendez vous demain pour
un dernier cap sur le rubik's cube les
dernières astuces et un petit bonus pour
une figure que vous pouvez faire avec
entraînez-vous bien je suis ravi que
vous sachiez maintenant faire un rubik's
cube
rendez vous demain 17h pour le prochain
mentale vlog ciao
oui